so during that period from 1972 to the
1970s it was like very developed slowly
and then it just sort of accelerated and
took on a life of its own and a lot a
lot of ideas that we had about chess
openings changed overnight one of the
most important ideas in chess openings
that was changed overnight
was the idea of the Morosi bind
let me put up a typical baroque see
buying position so this move see to see
for typifies the mirach see bind white
gets pawns on c4 and E for black has a
pawn on d6 and when giza baroque see a
grandmaster from hungary back in the 30s
40s came up with this concept people
were frightened to death they thought
that black was going to get throttled
because he was so cramped in space that
White's pawns on c4 and E for literally
strangled the opponent well in the 70s a
more like the 80s and 90s I really want
to say a whole new chapter of chess
understanding developed and blossomed
and black started playing a defense
against the Morosi bind called the
hedgehog and virtually every top
grandmaster in the world was using the
hedgehog as black with the exception of
one player Viktor Korchnoi Viktor
Korchnoi always strongly strongly
vehement Lee believed that white had a
huge nearly decisive
advantage against the Hedgehog and the
wonderful thing about the Hedgehog if
you just look at this position for a
moment is the idea is that it's so
transpositional you get the Hedgehog
positions out of all kinds of openings
and defenses for example the English c4
and variation c5 Knight f3 d6 d4 CD 94
Knight f6 Knight c3 a6 e4 d 6 bang
you're right in the hedgehog so you can
get it from the Sicilian you can get it
from Queen ponds openings you can get it
from English's it's massively
transpositional and it's almost in a
sense like the isolated Queen pond
positions that you can get isolated
Queen ponds positions come from both
sides of the table black can get an
isolated queen pawn white can get a
isolated Queen pond and they come from
all kinds of openings and defenses and
so does the Hedgehog and so this the
Hedgehog was an incredibly incredibly
versatile defense and I'd like to show
you examples although everybody has
played the Hedgehog okay just a second
there we go and we're going to we're
going to play the Hedgehog from the
black side of black point of view and
try to understand it by the way showing
how far ahead of his time he was there
was an exhibition game that was played
between yon Timman pardon not yon Timon
he's a poet of mine Bobby Fischer and
Olfa Anderson Oh Henderson from Sweden
they played an exhibition game and Bobby
played the hedgehog attack and he came
up with a very very modern strategy
during this exhibition game that was a
of a model for the Hedgehog anatoly
karpov when he was world champion used
the hedgehog lies for dish Oh Anderson
was exceptionally good in the hedgehog
and you'll see many many examples if you
look at their games this particular game
that I want to show you there's a
there's a double purpose in this game
Viktor Korchnoi and I that's me over
here we played in the Zagreb inter-zonal
tournament
what was that year again 1987 yes
industrial Graz nough was our hotel ah
ok and this was an extremely interim
portant tournament because
that wasn't supposed to happen
because only that only the top I want to
say the top three players in a very
large field of a let's say 20 players
advance to the World Championships so I
had to be in the top three and Viktor
Korchnoi and I when we played this game
we it was the penultimate game the last
game at the tournament he was doing
exceptionally well I was doing
exceptionally well and if I make a draw
in this game then it meant that I was
probably going to qualify for the World
Championships so Viktor Korchnoi was a
beast with white he was doing terrible
things to his opponents scoring horrible
results something like 75 80 % with the
white pieces so everybody feared Viktor
Korchnoi and when he was white most
especially so I have a big test in front
of me I have to play Viktor Korchnoi I
need a draw win of course I qualify for
the world championships but a very very
important game and this is one of my
most painful defeats of all time
if if anybody ever said to me
yessir what were your most painful
losses this one isn't the top two I mean
is really really really hurt and let's
see what so so first of all it's a big
test for me I have to make a careful
choice of the defense that I want to
play and I knew I knew with absolute
certainty that if I did play the
Hedgehog against Victor it was going to
be like waving a red bull in front of a
red flag in front of an angry bull that
I mean that would really provoke him so
my idea in the Hedgehog as we're about
to see it's very very transpositional we
haven't quite reached the position I
want yet is in this particular variation
of the Hedgehog white has not yet played
efore the Morosi buying position but
what White has is this big pawn on c4
against my passive pawn on d6 but one of
the strengths of the Hedgehog is that
even though you have a cramp position
when you're black all your pieces are
actually in harmony so if we think about
this for a second this Bishop on b7 has
an open dialogue pretty good this knight
on f6 pretty good this night on d7
protects the knight on f6 it can jump to
e5 and c5 Bishop on g7 pretty good once
I castle my king will be in safety and
furthermore there is this little pot
pesky this pawn on c4 that is on a
half-open C file so it's very clear that
my rook is going to come to c8 and I'm
going to put pressure on this bond okay
let's continue
castles Queen d2 with this move Viktor
gets out of a potential ambush of my
bishop
I was ready to jump with my Knight to e4
I think that's what I did
knight on e4 Knight takes bishop takes
and I was always very grateful to have
such a position where my bishop on g7
had an open diagonal so at this point I
was very very satisfied with the outcome
of my opening even though the theory the
classical theory at the time was that
this position was much to the advantage
of white okay but I just knew I knew
Victor would come gunning for me okay so
Queen c7 Bishop h3 so what would this
move what I wanted to do was I wanted to
put a battery on the diagonal with my
Queen and Bishop Victor was afraid that
if he moved his knight I would trade
bishops and with every trade of peace
his chances for an advantage would go
further further down so with this move
Bishop h3 first of all Victor gets out
of the potential pin that might occur
after Queen b7 secondly his idea is that
this bishop on h3 it's kind of annoying
I want to put my rook on c8 so he's
anticipating that and he's thinking that
his Bishop on h3 is well placed okay so
we continued so rugby eight this move
deserves a little explanation what was
my idea behind the move rook b8 yes
young lady
precisely so maybe in the SU properly
explained maybe in the future I could
play moves like a six and B five and if
I cannot this pawn it just make a trade
if I could take this pawn off the board
and this pawn off the board and not lose
my queen while doing it by the way the
whites control over the d5 square would
be nullified completely nullified so 90
for Bishop ah a eight so the purpose of
this move is that I want to make a queen
Bishop and queen battery checkmate
white on the h1 square and provoke white
to play the move f2 f3 Knight b5 Queen
b7 f3 a six-night here again everything
from my point of view has been flowing
very very nicely and again I would say
that I was very satisfied as was Viktor
Korchnoi
because Victor's idea is that he has a
very good grip over the d5 square
he wants to bring his Knight to d5
nullify my Queen and Bishop from my
point of view what I started thinking
was if my knight jumps to the e5 square
not only do i attack his pawn on c4 but
maybe just maybe I could sacrifice my
nightie on f3 and Czech made them on the
long diagonal and finally and most
importantly I am now preparing the
advance of my pawn b6 b5 there we go
Knight d5 now if we go back just to move
here what I would have liked to have
seen is Viktor capture my pawn yeah and
I capture his pawn
and in the case that he goes Knight to
d5 attacking my pawn on e7 my intention
was to go here with my knight defending
my pawn threatening perhaps to play
Knight c4 and after a move like rook
here I was thinking I was planning I beg
your pardon I was planning this position
and I was very happy about this position
because I thought I had the better
chances I had already knocked his pawn
control over d5 my pawn on d5 is
limiting the activity of his to pond and
in case he was to capture my pawn on d6
I have the very simple Knight c4 and
he's in deep trouble his Bishop is
attacked on e3 isn't his rook on d6 is
attacked and best of all if he goes back
I could simply win an exchange and
probably the game yeah so I'm feeling
really good at this point
and again I was hoping that he would
trade instead he played the move Knight
d5 and things start really heating up
well one of the strengths of the
Hedgehog position is that although your
pieces sometimes you get cramped you
have a very solid position both in the
center on the Kings side on the Queen
side so in this particular position we
can see several threats by white he
intends to take and maybe bring his rook
two to c7 wouldn't be very good we can
see that he threatens to take the pawn
on e7 with check and that wouldn't be
very good I played the movie 7e six
attacking his knight because we things
start to get very very sharp in a hurry
in a sense after this move he has no
choice and we both calculated very very
deeply into the position and we both
came to the same conclusion that would
best play the game is going to be your
draw knight east 7 check basically
forced King over now it's very clear
that this guy is like on a guerrilla
mission
it's jumped into my position but is
there any guarantee that it's going to
get out of my position alive in other
words if I could play moves like 95 or
rook e8 this night might be trapped so
the play was very forced at c5 there was
something wrong with Queen takes d6 and
I've got to try to remember what it is
Queen takes d6 what would have happened
after Queen takes d6 new variation I
think the answer was simply Knight e5
pawn takes Queen takes with a double it
with a kind of a triple attack if you
will I'm threatening to take the pawn on
e 2 I'm threatening to take the pawn on
b2 but I'm also threatening to play
Knight C for attacking Queen Bishop and
again notice that this knight on e7 is a
little bit stranded it's deep inside my
territory but is it a target is it a
liability or an asset ok check here c5
only move and I played Knight e5 and he
took my pawn on d6 now at least his
knight has protection
the pawn on d6 and so he's not fearful
of being captured for free this is a
very important property about the night
that will understand as we go through
our levels from class players to experts
to masters so very important property
that the knight has the more the knight
is defended the stronger the knight is
the more the knight is defended the
stronger the night becomes okay and it's
very interesting a moment ago the night
wasn't that strong now with the pawn on
d6 it is night c4 attacking his queen
he's got a play rook takes e4 takes d7
okay this was the forcing variation that
we had both seen yeah now I thought that
I could that the variation I calculated
that I thought was either winning or
drawing for me I I don't know if I was
excited or nervous or both I was
thinking of Queen tags B to d8 Queen
yeah okay
wild position right rook takes d8 now
obviously he can't take my queen he
takes my rook pretty good so far so so
far I had this picture in my mind when I
played the move b5 several moves earlier
and I was thinking that if I take his
Queen
he takes my queen my rook I play Bishop
here he plays Bishop here and I'm lost
checkmate on f8 is rather inevitable but
if we look at this position for a second
two moves not one but two moves were
going through my mind the first move
that was going through my mind is look
at my bishop on a eight look at my
bishop on a eight if just for a moment
if just for a moment that diagonal was
open Wow wouldn't it be marvelous how
about Queen takes e to in the first
place I'm attacking his Bishop on aa III
in the second place I want to play Queen
takes f3 and suddenly that diagonal for
my Bishop is open I could check meet him
and at the moment this night on e7 if
you look about if you look at that night
again and again and again it doesn't
really have that many squares it's not
like Knight takes g6 as a threat or
Knight f5 or 95 and I see that night is
like hanging in midair it's it's not
that effective in the meantime I want to
take the bishop or take the pawn so I
was thinking that his move which was
forced was Queen d2 I would take the
pawn and my threat of checkmate on h1
was so powerful it would require him to
back up with the bishop and now lots of
variations were going through my mind
including could I step back with my
queen to try to pick up this knight here
or should I
go into this ending Queen takes Queen
takes bishop takes King takes and again
notice that this knight on e7 is kind of
trapped and I'm hopeful that one day
I'll be able to play c2 Bishop b2 and
rook c1 not entirely satisfied that that
was a good variation for me another
thought came to my mind and that was in
this position I don't have to take this
pawn on e to I could play a very tricky
move I'm trying to remember what I was
thinking
Queen here why would I play Queen a3
what's up with that what's going on
after Queen a3
why would I consider that move as a
possibly good move
don't all jump in there at once yes
attacking the bishop on e3 with check
absolutely no question about that also
what else what else what else yes hang
lady
precisely that's right so my queen is
starting to eyeball the night on e7 so
that rook takes d8 rook takes d8 Bishop
f8 I'll be able to have the defense
queen takes a seven when I need to in
the meantime his Bishop on e3 is under
threat and it wasn't that intuitively
obvious to me what white should do so
for example if white went back bishop c1
I could play Queen check King g2 now in
this case I could take the I could
finally take the Queen take the rook
Bishop here Bishop here Queen takes this
is what grandmasters do they look they
think about all of these positions and
they try to make a judgement in this
moment this Bishop is very bad but
unfortunately this pond just isn't
making it in time this bishop can come
back and defend the C 1 square and I was
trying to make a variation like this
work and what occurred to me was in this
position takes takes I should just get
my pawn going that I should play the
move c3 okay so now in my mind's eye
what I was thinking is remember a moment
ago when I took the pawn on e 2 and he
came back with his queen I took the pawn
on f3 and he had to defense Bishop g2
well obviously with my pawn already on
the square c3 I'm denying the Queen's
retreat simultaneous
Lee I want to push my pawn to c2 so that
eventually one day I could capture his
Queen what would you do if you were
white what on earth can white do
mmm guys are having trouble this is good
so throw out some ideas anybody got some
really clever obnoxious ideas that I'd
have to deal with
hmm well one of the things that we could
think about for a moment is like where
if you're white you were perhaps be
fearful about the pawn on e 2 and you
should perhaps be fearful about the pond
going to C 2 so one move you would
certainly want to consider is Queen D 3
correct so the idea behind the move
Queen D 3 is that you're if you're white
you would be prepared to meet the move C
2 with rook C 1 and capturing the pond
so far so good but what do you think
about the night on e7 how could black
attack the night on e7 and isn't the
night on e7 trapped
right or it could black do if you play
the move Bishop f6 white hat attacking
the knight White has Bishop d4 so
attacking the bishop the night with the
bishop doesn't make sense
rook coming here threatening to capture
isn't really a threat because there's
queen d8 MIT queen a3 both queen a3 and
queen bee four would suffice and black
is doing perfectly fine so all of these
variations I was liking for myself
and I thought that gosh I could win this
position and boy that qualifies me for
the World Championship and my level of
optimism was zooming zooming zooming
zooming higher so let's see what
happened we got to this position and I
played the move rook d8 because I had it
in mind that after Queen takes beat oops
excuse me after Queen takes beat I did
it wrong I sorry
there it is the Queen takes b2 --tags
--tags c3 where's my c3 move c3 yep c3
- and what did I say queen d3 and queen
a3 there's a move here that I saw for
white that I thought would was saving
him
what could white do in this position
that saves his position
what could white do that would save his
position
yes sir
Bishop d4 Bravo Bravo bishop the d4
queen takes bishop takes King takes
Queen takes and even-steven ending and
at this point I was playing for a win so
I didn't want to make a draw and I
played the move sorry
d7 rook da so I was playing for a win
but we both saw the variation that Saul
just pointed out that would have made a
draw
okay so Viktor found
Bishop d4 which I thought was the only
defensive move Queen B for so my idea
was all I got to do is trade Queens and
it's game over I'm attacking the knight
on e7 and I thought my winning chances
in this position were better than that
position that Saul showed that that
white could make a draw and here I was
supremely confident supremely confident
that things were really going my way
what did White play what did white play
yes Henry
Bishop's III I'm going to take your
night and man 92 slips no let's see what
it would have happened had he played
Knight takes g6 first of all I was very
very fearful of this move Knight takes
g6 it's like one of those things that
you make the move Queen before and then
you know like the 10 minutes that it
took you to make the move the moment I
was releasing my queen it's like I saw
everything and Knight takes g6 I had
discounted that Knights ability to do
any damage for very very many moves and
suddenly the last move Bishop d4 has set
up the possibility of Queen h6 check and
I saw that coronally could take my pawn
takes takes takes check and that he
would have a draw by perpetual check
that is to say I can't move back with my
king because of this one yes and I have
to go up with my king or away with my
king and then he could make a pepper
actual check yeah oh dear
so I had just released my Queen Queen B
for when it suddenly occurred to me that
night g6 gives him a draw and he was in
time trouble and he played the move
Queen g5 and that move was a real
surprise for me because I had been so
focused upon him playing the move Knight
takes g6 and making a draw but then I
was looking at this position a little
bit more and suddenly it was like a
kaboom boo boo boo boo boo boo boo boo
boo boo boo my heart starts beating
because I saw a very severe threat
at 5:00 light Queen f6 so instead of
going for the perpetual check he's now
going for the win after Queen f6 he's
setting up all kinds of check mating
patterns and themes I play pretty good I
think I played Queen b5 okay so I'm
setting him up again
so my idea besides give me your queen
was also give me your pawn and now why
isn't Queen f6 a good move yes exactly
I'm 3o if he plays Queen f6 c5 on the
spot resigns he's losing a piece what
did he play
what did he play
yes Michael
I'm sorry Knight takes g6 check Bravo
Bravo
Knight takes g6 takes and now sorry now
I saw that he has a perpetual check okay
so here I was expecting him to make a
perpetual check when suddenly and very
unexpectedly oh dear oh dear
rook to d4 and now it was my turn to
panic because before I was rejecting
lines where we were going to make a draw
and I was playing for the win now I have
allowed him to make a perpetual check
and suddenly he's playing for the win
with the move rook d4 what's his idea
very simply he wants to play rook h4
check he will force my queen to block
the check then he will play bishop takes
and I'll be totally messed up by his
pawn on d7 is a killer pawn so in this
position on one move I blundered the
game away this is so painful Oh with one
move I blundered the game away what move
should i what was my proper correct
defensive move what should I have done
what should I do rook h4 is a killing
threat gotta stop it right young man
Queen b6 what did you think
Queen b6 as well I played the losing
move Queen b6 so worried I'm not the
only one that would have blown it now we
know that Queen b6 is not the correct
move let's try to find the move that is
correct okay I'll give you a clue when I
play the move Queen b6 it's clear that
the rook is in a absolute pin the rook
can't go to h4 but when I play the move
Queen b6 how could he break the absolute
print bingo precisely so I have played
the move Queen b6 and after Queen b6 e 3
AI ended up taking the rook okay but if
I had played route Bishop takes f3 he
has to take now Queen b6 check King back
now he's still in the pin and after he
gets out of the pin I play h5 in order
to play king h6 and the game's alight
what I did in the game was I played
Queen b6 III and now my intended defense
because I of course saw what was
happening
my intended defense was Bishop takes f3
I got to this position
I was about to capture this pawn when I
had one of those horrible Emma shocking
realizations white can win by force
how could white win by force young man
exactly I suddenly saw a row gauge for
Bishop h5 which I thought was saving my
tattoos but now rook takes h5 check G
takes Queen f6 is checkmate if I take
with the rook with my king how does how
does white win and Lady Queen h4 whoops
you know it's funny that you say Queen
h4 and that's mate what I saw in my mind
was create seven King g5 Queen h4 your
checkmate is much more efficient you
could in one move this was bad enough
when I saw this one ah
so very very painfully my awareness I
realized I didn't have Bishop takes f3 I
took took took took and quickly resigned
soon I think that this was just some
kind of time trouble and I and I
resigned Queen takes h7 checkmate it
should take sensory so this was a really
really painful game right so after the
game in the New York Times they
published an article that you know Sarah
won knocked out of the World
Championship and they called
Viktor Korchnoi game a brilliant
sacrificial game that won in all
variations because like no I was the one
playing for the wind and I could have
made
awww many many ways long story short in
the very final round I was in a must-win
situation and I needed some other
results to go in my favor and everything
worked like a charm and I did qualify
but what a heart attack I had with this
one